[MUSIC PLAYING]
OSCAR WAHLTINEZ: Hi, everyone.
Thank you all for coming.
Great to see so
many people here.
My name is Oscar.
I am from the Developer
Relations Team.
And today we're going
to speak about Camera.
And this session will
cover three major topics.
First, we're going to talk about
the inner workings of camera
on Android.
Second, Snap is
here with us today.
They're going to
showcase how they
use the Camera
APIs in production
to millions of users.
And we're going to close with
our vision of the future of how
Camera API should evolve and
the ecosystem that goes with it.
Let's jump right in.
Developing Camera app is
a series of compromises.
Some are outside your
control as a developer.
But understanding
those will help
you make better decisions
where you have control
within your app.
Let's go over how Camera
works at the physical level.
As any decent
photographer knows,
it is a biplane of steps
at the physical level.
Visible light goes
through a lens
that directs it to filters,
which passes the light
onto millions of light sensors.
Then that converts
the light, finally,
into a 2D matrix of pixels.
When you think light
sensors, the first thing
that may come to mind
is the almighty CCD.
Nowadays, we have many other
kinds, such a CMOS or APS,
that are actually
more commonly used
in today's modern cameras,
DSLRs, phones, et cetera.
From now on, we refer to this
component as the Camera Module.
The output of the Camera
Module is our raw picture,
a raw frame.
It is not entirely
unprocessed, but it has not
been processed outside of the
Camera Module at this stage.
You can think of
the Camera Module
as a black box that
dispatches these frames.
In early hardware, we
had three physical pins
for different kinds of pictures.
Nowadays, the modern
designs, we have a single pin
thanks to tricks
like multiplexing,
and higher clock
speeds, and so forth.
But the conceptual model remains
as having separate processing
pipelines for each
kind of image.
We have, generally speaking,
three broad use cases--
video preview, photo,
and video recording.
We'll cover those separately.
The Camera Module, as
I said, is a black box.
And it contains an increasing
amount of smarts within,
some of which are in a
closed feedback loop.
We, as developers, will
have very little visibility
into what goes on in there.
To give you an example, when
you set, say, auto focus or auto
white balance, the
Camera Module may
be looking for faces to
see how to better optimize
those settings.
And you don't really have
any control over that.
From a framework
standpoint, all developers
do is send one configuration
in, and you get one frame out.
This is very, very important.
You send one configuration
in, one frame out.
For each frame, there
is a configuration
that goes with it.
To help you with this, we have a
set of template configurations.
We'll cover those
later, as well.
So let's zoom into the preview
pipeline, the one on top.
As I said, each biplane
shown is a broad use case.
When it comes to preview,
you can think of it
as the viewfinder.
So whenever somebody is
holding their phone up
and you want to see
what the camera sees,
this is the use case
we're talking about.
We need to compromise
on some things.
Obviously, the camera can only
do so many things at once.
When it comes to
preview, we choose
to compromise on quality.
We care much more about latency.
We want the user to
be able to see what
the camera sees much faster.
This just generally
results in better latency,
because we're able to
compromise, as I said,
on quality.
Some of those compromises come
in the form of, for example,
reduced motion stabilization
or less noise reduction.
Moving onto the
photo pipeline, you
may want to enable our users
to capture high-quality images.
Keep in mind, as I said before,
one frame configuration in,
one frame out.
Different frame
configuration may
mean that you will not be able
to reuse the same raw frame.
One example of
this is if you are
requesting different exposure.
So at the physical
level, the sensor
needs to expose the frame for
a different period of time.
That means that
you're going to have
a different frame entirely.
If you are mindful while
you set up your pipelines,
you may be able to avoid
this compromise entirely.
So when it comes
to photos, we care
much more about the quality,
a lot less about the speed.
So we choose to compromise on
that latency in lieu of having
much better-quality image.
Lastly, we have
the video pipeline.
This is for the video
record use case.
As the diagram indicates, you're
saying that all these pipelines
should be parallel, in theory.
In practice, we have a
number of bottlenecks.
And frames can only come
so fast out of the camera.
Some of those bottlenecks
include the exposure time.
Some of them can be the
processing power, memory,
bandwidth limits, and a
number of other things.
In the video pipeline,
it's almost a blend
of the previous two.
We care about the speed.
We definitely need to have
frames coming consistently
out of the camera
at a certain rate.
But at the same time, we
also care about quality.
So it is very important that,
in this kind of use case,
we find the right balance.
Generally speaking, we can
only test for so many things.
Android runs in many, many
devices, not just the high end,
but you're talking
about the low end, too.
Unfortunately, we can only
test, as I said, so many things.
In general, the
best test scenario
is when you have
preview pipeline running
plus one other.
You're going to have
a really hard time
if you want to have all
three pipelines running
simultaneously.
So we discussed trade-offs
made by the hardware.
We discussed trade-offs
made by the framework.
And now we're going to dive
into the application layer,
what we, as developers, can do.
Let's walk through the
end-to-end process of a frame,
from the creation of a request
until the pictures are finally
in memory, ready for us to use.
Follow the steps, [? USC-ABC, ?]
and then profit will just fall
in your lap.
If you don't believe
me, ask Snapchat.
The first decision you
have to make as a developer
is selecting the right
device out of the ones
available on your list.
Device here means the
Camera Module, not
devices in the phone device.
Each phone may have
multiple cameras.
Generally speaking, you probably
have at least one front,
one back.
This is especially important now
that we have Multi-Camera APIs.
You may have multiple devices
that are, say, back facing
that you can choose from.
So you will have to go
through all those devices
and see which one fits
your use case best.
Once you've successfully
opened the camera,
you're going to get the
camera device instance.
And that is necessary
to proceed forward
in the open camera callback.
You can use the
very same callback
to monitor the status
of your camera device.
It is entirely possible
that the camera
may be yanked from you if
a higher-priority process
requires the device.
This could happen very easily
in a multi-window environment,
for example.
Second step, you need to
allocate your camera output
targets.
This is where each of the
pipelines that we showed
earlier are going to copy your
frames in the form of buffers.
The memory may
already be allocated.
Then all you need to
do is to get reference
to the underlying surface
and pass it as a target.
Otherwise, you may have
to wait for a callback.
Once the targets are
ready, the capture session,
which is specific to the device
that you open, can be created.
It is worth noting
that, as I said,
the camera capture session
is specific to that device
that you open earlier.
Once the session is ready, you
can build a capture request.
One of the predefined
templates must be used.
If you don't want to take any
of the hints from the system,
you can use template
manual for full control.
Otherwise, the
framework is going
to provide a set
of templates that
closely align to the camera
conceptual model we discussed
earlier.
So you have templates for video.
You have templates for photo.
And you have
templates for record.
The capture request contains
specific frame configuration
and the output target.
Recall, frame configuration
in, output frame out.
A couple of things to
know is the output target
must be one of the
previously defined ones.
You cannot just use another
surface here and attach it.
It needs to be one
of the surfaces
that you declare first
as part of the session.
This is the configuration
part of it--
of the configuration
in, frame out.
To recap, we've chosen the
camera device that we want.
We created the camera session
for that particular device.
And now we built a
capture request that
will be used in that session.
We can finally ask
for a camera frame.
We send the capture
request to the session,
and then we wait
for the callback.
We can do this in two ways.
We can send the
request once, or we can
make it a repeating request.
This makes more sense in
use cases like, for example,
preview or video record.
You don't want to be
sending that configuration
for every single frame.
This is a very easy way to
just send one configuration
and ask the framework to
continuously repeat it.
Now, which callback do
you want to listen to?
That really depends on what
you want to get out of it.
If you want to get
the frame metadata,
you should look inside
of the capture callback.
If you want to get the
frame for CPU processing,
one of the options is
using image reader.
Generally speaking, you can just
get whatever pixel information
out of the output surface
that you had set up.
Image reader is just one of
the easiest ways to do it.
If you want to get
that into the GPU,
a great idea is running
script allocations.
Obviously, that's
not the only choice.
You can also use OpenGL,
text, or buffers.
And this is the cycle,
step one through five,
that we need to go through
for every single frame.
Recall, one configuration in,
one frame out, and a bunch
of trade-offs in the process.
MUSTAFA ABRAR: All
right, thanks, Oscar.
My name is Mustafa Abrar.
I'm a software engineer at Snap.
And so I work on
the Snapchat app.
Today what I want to do is take
what Oscar said about the lower
layers of the camera,
and work up to your app,
and design choices
that you make,
and how they influence how
you interact with the camera.
We'll talk about
some trade-offs,
in terms of architecture, how to
architect the camera framework
inside of your app.
And we'll talk about specific
challenges in a more narrow use
case.
So nowadays, if you've
ever used Snapchat--
I'm hoping everyone has--
the first thing that
happens is it opens directly
into the camera.
And the reason for this is
that people use the camera now
as a means of communication.
They're taking a
picture, or they're
adding metadata creativity,
and then sending it.
And so it's really
like the cursor,
where what you have to say
and trying to get that out
as quickly as possible is
the thing we really value.
There are a few key
camera design decisions
that we've made, and
these will influence how
we interact with the camera.
The first of those
is full screen.
In video, in pictures,
front camera, rear camera,
all of them are full screen.
Now you typically don't see
this on a lot of cameras.
If you take your camera
out, usually picture mode
is 4 by 3 aspect ratio.
Because a lot of times,
you share it online.
The camera actually optimized
for specific aspect ratios.
And so, since your display
is usually 16 by 9,
or some other aspect
ratio that might not
be available for picture mode,
we have to make a trade-off.
Usually, the devices will
have something that matches,
but it might be really
high resolution.
And to just encode that
and create a JPEG out of it
just takes a long time.
So we have to make trade-offs,
in terms of the resolution
we select for taking pictures
and video, and so forth.
The second part is single mode.
There's no video mode.
You don't swipe and
enter a video mode.
And when you have
this design choice,
it leads to a set
of optimizations
you can't take advantage.
For example, videos, there's
a recording hint on Android
that you can tell the system
the user is about to record.
There's a lot of optimizations
that you can set.
But if you don't know
the user's intent,
if they long press, it's
a video, if they just
take a picture, a single
tap, you don't know ahead.
So you can't decide upfront
what configurations are always
going to work.
We try to do static
configurations that
are good in a lot of scenarios.
And then we have certain
that are dynamic,
and we update those depending
on what the user's intent is.
The other part is, for
a long time, Snapchat
has offered lenses, a lot of
interactive features inside
of the camera.
And each of those things
forces certain trade-offs.
For example, if there's a lot
of motion, your face is moving,
and you're trying to track
a user's face, optical image
stabilization-- there's a lot of
things that might not work well
with these other things that
want to keep track of where
the user is.
Also, it has a lot
of memory overhead.
There's a lot of
GPU work going on.
And you need to balance
all the work that you do.
The last part is
you can't cheat.
You have to capture the
picture in front of the users
so they can get their message
out as fast as possible.
Most cameras, if you take a
picture, it hides the latency
and it saves in the background.
So you don't see it.
It just kind of falls away.
And you don't really see
how long it actually takes.
But for us-- because the
real meat is when users edit
the canvas of their
image or their video--
we have to do it
right there and then.
And so you have to make certain
trade-offs to have low latency
to get there.
Now to support these
and some other features,
you need to think about how
the overall architecture
of your app is going
to be if you truly
want it to be universal.
So there's a few best
practices that I'll share.
Some of them really just
help and broaden the width
of devices that
you're able to target,
and also how well they
perform on those devices.
And over time,
you're going to add
features, lenses, interaction.
So you want a framework that's
extensible so that you could
plug and play different things.
So the first thing you
have to interact with
is the API that Oscar mentioned.
It's the part you
interact with the camera.
And there's a set of APIs.
There's two versions.
There's Camera1.
And it's been around
for many years.
And then there's also
a Camera2, a newer API.
Although Camera1
is deprecated, when
you have hundreds of
millions of users,
it's a big chunk that's
still on Camera1.
So you need to
support it, regardless
of what the device says.
The second part is there's
different modes for Camera2.
For OEMs to slowly adapt,
they have a legacy mode,
which is simply we've
made our API work.
But under the hood,
it's really Camera1.
And also, Camera2
varies by device.
Some devices say, yep,
Camera2 works great here.
But in reality, deep
down, it's still Camera1.
And so the performance you get
might vary even across devices.
So you really need to know
each of the different products
that you want to target.
And so what we do
is we support both.
Since 2016, we've written
both Camera1 and Camera2,
in terms of code.
And then what we do is we add
a layer on top that's basically
what our application
sees to just unify
what it looks like underneath.
And then if you have
shared code, for example,
picking resolution,
it doesn't really
matter which version
you're using.
The logic for the full
screen that I mentioned
can be shared by both.
So there's some shared code.
But the application
deals with the top part.
The next part is there's
millions of devices.
A lot of them have bugs.
They say they support
a certain feature.
It doesn't work.
You zoom in beyond
99%, some bug comes.
So we have a lot
of configuration
that allows us to decide
on specific devices
and models what behavior,
what configuration, to adopt.
And so this remote
configuration is really key.
And over time, you
have to groom it.
You have to maintain it.
It's a very key part of
something that's just code.
Now let's build up
this architecture.
So I've talked a bit about
the camera interaction,
the code that talks to
the camera server, which
is the Android system process
that manages the camera.
And it talks through
binder IPC, which
is a form of intraprocess
communication.
But if you expose this
to your applications,
it's a little too raw.
Because you might have a
video chat feature, a camera,
and video node.
And if they all try
to talk to the camera,
they could do things that sort
of conflict with each other.
There's life cycling, a lot of
things you need to be aware of.
And so what we do is we
have an operation queue that
allows us to coalesce
things that are redundant,
allows us to manage
invalid states.
And so we avoid a lot
of conflicting things
across features by having an
operation queue and a thread
that processes them.
And the next part
is-- so everything
on your right, the gray
side, is really about the UI.
The shutter button you see,
the autofocus, the animations,
all that.
And then it has a state
machine that says,
OK, the user tapped autofocus.
Let's do the animation.
Let's ask the
camera to autofocus.
And then it saves
your intent in memory
and tries to drive the
asynchronous process
to get it done.
And so the right-hand side
and the left-hand side
have different responsibilities.
And then over time,
your surface comes in.
That's the preview frames
that Oscar was saying.
It starts showing
up on your screen.
If you have interactive
features enabled,
like lenses, they get
composited on top of it.
And this is done in OpenGL.
And we try to do it
synchronously and not
avoid copying anything large.
And then ultimately, your
UI is composited on top.
And so, as far as the
user is concerned,
it all looks integrated.
But in reality,
it's multiple layers
that are coming together.
Now, if you look at this
architecture, what you notice
is that the left and the
right have different things
that you're concerned about.
And one way to think about it
is client server architecture.
The right-hand side
is like the client.
The left-hand side is your
runtime, your processing.
And the concerns are different.
So from a performance
perspective,
the left-hand side needs to
worry about processing frames
really fast.
It needs to worry about
stability, a lot of things.
And the right-hand side is
really about animations,
new features, a
lot of the candy,
in terms of how the user
interacts with the camera.
And so one cool
thing you can do is,
if you ever work
with client server,
sometimes a server is slow.
It takes hundreds of
milliseconds, sometimes
some issues.
So what we do is we have
ways of replacing components.
You can use Dagger.
You have other
approaches where you say,
OK, let's just
abstract out the camera
so that the UI thinks it's
talking to the real thing.
And we'll just mock the
APIs to the Android system
and maybe do a no op, or
send black frames-- whatever
we want to do.
And one place where we
take advantage of this
is performance testing.
So for example, if
you add new UI logic
and you want to
see if it regresses
the camera in any way,
you don't care how long
the camera operations take.
And because they're
variable-- if, let's say,
it takes 100 milliseconds
to open the camera,
and it's variable because
it's a system service--
then, over time,
you might not be
able to catch
10-millisecond regressions.
And so in this example
here, what I'm showing
is a startup regression
test with a mock camera.
So the camera has
been mocked out.
It's starting the app
repeatedly and saying,
OK, let's collect the metrics
and see how long it's taking
to get to a stable point.
And then we can actually
catch regressions
across several
commits to see what
change might have caused it.
Another example is, instead
of replacing the whole camera,
you can replace part of it.
You could say, the frames
that are coming out,
let's just replace them with
something else, rather than
the whole camera.
You could keep other
functionality intact.
And so in this case here,
we could replace the frames
with a video file.
And so this is very useful in
situations where, let's say,
you're automatically
testing your face tracking.
In the lab environment where
you run integration tests,
there's no faces.
There's no people in the
lab to look at the camera.
And so what we do is we
actually use the video files
to drive that interaction.
So here's a picture of
me running some lenses
testing where the frames
have been mocked out
from a video file.
And so there's me.
Hello, I/O.
And you can see
the paper showing.
It's not the camera.
It's just the video.
But everything else is real.
It took a snap.
It edits it.
It does a lot of things.
So you can mock out
parts of the camera
to allow you to add
new features and just
test things in isolation.
And so this is--
in terms of an architecture,
it's one way to do it.
There's many ways.
But this gives you the
performance considerations
on the left, the
remote configuration
to get a wide range
of devices supported,
to have different
cameras, multiple cameras,
front-facing, rear.
And so the remote configurations
for that, the performance
considerations in the UI
and the extensibility.
Now let's jump into
a specific use case.
Snapchat's known.
The majority of our
media is just images.
And everyone always asks,
how do you guys take photos?
How does it all work?
And we break it up
into several stages.
The first stage is capturing,
quickly capturing the content
so that you can actually
process and allow
the user to be creative.
Once they add all
their creatives,
you composite all of the
different layers of creativity
that they've done
and you transcode it
into something that is
efficient to transport over
the network to the recipient.
And the last part is rendering.
That's the part where the
recipient looks at the content.
And depending on
the choices you make
in your player can really
affect the quality of the images
that they see.
And all of these are
complicated things.
And we have teams
dedicated to each one.
But I'll just touch on the
capturing one for today.
Now, Oscar mentioned you
tell the camera, hey, capture
a frame.
And you wait back.
And your callback is called.
But there's a lot of latency
involved in this step.
In Camera1, the API is
called Take Picture.
And it takes 400 milliseconds
on a really high-end phone
from last year.
Whereas, if you take
the preview frame that's
optimized for low latency, it's
an order of magnitude smaller.
And you can see the
P90s are quite high.
And so what we do is,
periodically, we'll
optimize, as much as we can,
our code for specific devices
that we feel are
pretty good latency.
And we enable it remotely
for users on those devices.
And users are delighted.
Wow, the quality went up.
It looks really cool.
It just happened today.
People notice it right away.
But also, they notice the delay.
And if you're trying
to communicate
and there's any
lag, or anything,
you'll notice it right away.
And so what we do is we
try to do a trade-off.
We do both.
We'll take picture and
screenshot in certain devices.
And if it takes too long, we
fall back to the screenshot.
So we have a lot of tricks
to work around this.
You can see examples here where
the quality, when you really
zoom in, is noticeable.
But it's not always a slam dunk.
In this case here, Take Picture
on the left is causing noise.
And sometimes the algorithms
might overcompensate,
and you'll see speckling.
So it's not always
just turn it on.
Certain front-facing
cameras, we disable it,
even though it can
sometimes result
in higher quality, especially
in low-light conditions.
So we balance that.
And so, really, it's a
hierarchy of trade-offs.
Oscar talked about
the low level.
You've got the design
choices of what
you've decided in your
application and, ultimately,
user intent.
Is the user sending a picture
to someone that's disappearing
and you want to favor
latency, versus is
the user preserving something?
So hopefully, some of
the tips we've shared
will help you guys build
a better Camera app.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
VINIT MODI: Thanks, Mustafa.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Vinit Modi.
I'm the Android
Camera Platform PM.
Oscar, earlier,
identified a series
of trade-offs required
to use the Camera2 APIs.
Mustafa further
elaborated on that theme
on how they applied
those trade-offs
in the real-world situations.
I'm going to change
the conversation a bit
and talk about how,
working together,
we can truly elevate both the
developer and the end user
experience.
The camera is evolving today.
It's moved on from
mere photography
as an immersive medium.
A great example of this
is what was demonstrated
in the keynote by [? Parna, ?]
where the camera is now
used to do geonavigation.
In addition, cameras
are everywhere today,
from IoT devices--
there's a great example in
the Android Things booth--
to your laptops, to
multiple cameras on devices.
And that's a trend that I
want you all to take away.
Devices with more than two
cameras are becoming the norm.
Recall the Camera
Model that Oscar talked
about earlier in the talk.
How do you extend that model
in a multi-camera situation?
Let's walk through an example.
Imagine a device with
three back cameras.
The native Camera
app today has access
to the physical streams
from each of these sensors.
In addition, the
native Camera app
has something called
the Logical Camera.
This is a virtual camera.
It's made up of all
the physical sensors.
It is a combined fused stream.
And it takes care of
some of the trade-offs
that Oscar and
Mustafa alluded to,
in terms of power,
performance, and latency.
So in the native Camera
app, you actually
have four cameras, one
virtual, three physical,
in a three-camera device.
But as developers, you only
get access to one of them.
This often depends on the
different types of devices.
And in this case, you
end up making trade-offs.
You're using the
APIs differently
from the native Camera app.
So we're pleased to announce
that, starting with Android P,
you'll get access
to all the cameras,
from the Logical Camera to
all the physical streams.
This applies to both the front
and back sensors, as well as
many different form factors.
Here's some example use cases.
The lady in the picture--
this is an image
of a bokeh mode.
You can use this
new Multi-Camera API
for depth, optical
vision, getting
monochrome frames directly
from the sensor, and many more.
But most of all, we're
excited of the use cases
that you guys are
going to build.
So let's walk through
this API real quick.
The first thing you would
do is check the camera
characteristics and check
if the device supports
the logical Multi-Camera API.
Next, you would check to see
which physical cameras make up
this logical device.
Today, we start support
for RGB and monochrome.
And we're looking to add more.
Here, it gets very
interesting when
you have a logical camera
that is abstracting
one front and one back sensor.
Finally, you would check to
see if the frames from all
of these sensors
are synchronized.
So I know what you're thinking.
Great, new API.
Which devices will support it?
Is it worth your time to
invest in this new API?
The answer is yes.
Starting with Android
P, all new devices
will support this new API.
And we're working
with many partners
to ensure that upgrade
devices also support this API.
So let me call out
a few partners.
We worked very
closely with Huawei
to ensure that monochrome
sensors are supported.
They actually helped
us test this API.
We worked with Xiaomi to
ensure that a majority
of their devices support
this API, as well.
So later this year,
you'll see devices
from both Huawei and
Xiaomi supporting
this new Multi-Camera API
on upgraded new devices.
And finally, the Android1 team.
We worked with
manufacturers from this team
to ensure that this API works
across all tiers of Android,
and is not exclusive
to just the high tier.
I want to share that,
together, we really can
elevate the camera experience.
Working with you, our
partners, our manufacturers,
we're really trying
to make sure that we
can bring amazing experiences.
And most of all, we're
very excited to see
what you're going to
build with these new APIs,
knowing what trade-offs you
need to make using these APIs.
We'd love to continue the
conversation in the after
session meeting space.
And thank you,
Oscar and Mustafa,
for sharing their insights.
Thank you, Snap,
for giving a glimpse
on how millions of users
get a delightful experience.
Thank you, everyone,
for attending.
Enjoy I/O.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]